París 2024 romperá la tradición y echará
abajo los muros de los estadios en 2017
mostró un adelanto de lo que vendrá
cuando una armada de aficionados
descendió el río Sena anunciándose como
sede de los próximos Juegos Olímpicos el
26 de julio de 2024 diez mil atletas se
subirán a más de 160 embarcaciones para
una ceremonia de apertura al aire libre
nunca antes vista
con un evento que será el orgullo de
Francia la ceremonia de apertura de
representar esa ambición por unos juegos
diferentes creativos y espectaculares
para la gente
normalmente la ceremonia de apertura es
vista por más de mil millones de
personas en todo el mundo la edición de
París contará con un público presencial
en torno a las seiscientas 1000 personas
en un recorrido de 6 kilómetros a lo
largo del río y de los principales
monumentos París el espectáculo contará
con holograma sobre el agua bailarines
en los tejados y espectáculos aéreos
quedan por anunciar las medidas que
aseguren un espectáculo de este calibre
y el lugar exacto donde se ubicará la
llama olímpica aunque hay una opción
bastante obvia una alta y puntiaguda